dankeschön 8 16 uhr dortmund hallo leute
ich ist wieder eure haltet eure mal
wanne und heute testen wir wieder das
ist der viscom hallo leute ich ist
wieder eure mai waren hallo leute ich es
wieder einmal waren und bekamen zu einem
neuen test heft fff 123 entschuldigt
meine stimme ich bin ein bisschen
erkältet deswegen klinge ich vielleicht
ein bisschen anders als sonst aber das
soll uns nicht davon abhalten leckere
sachen immer unseren mund zu stecken und
sich fragt was war was ist mit den
haaren das ist eine steckdose gefasst
wie gesetzt ich wollte mal ausprobieren
und sind es sehr gut ist das eigene
dauerwelle ich bin mir nicht so sicher
was mit dauerwelle ist aber wir sind
jetzt hier nicht zum diskutieren sondern
zum essen deswegen fange gleich mit der
ersten sache an was absolut nicht fehlen
darf man über süßigkeiten aus meiner
kindheit spricht
diese schlug zuckerketten da ich habe
die so geliebt und immer wenn man auch
ein kindergeburtstag bauen diese bunte
tüte bekommen hat waren die meistens
auch drin und dann kannst du mal ganz
lässig an der seite stehen und sie so im
vornehmen hamburger mission auch machen
wir weiter
eine bunte tüte nach ist für mich
kindheit gut neben unserer schule war
nämlich der krise das war ein friseur
wohnt man süßigkeiten kaufen konnte und
immer dann macht er schon dass man
gesagt gäste noch zum friseur was haben
wir hier drin rufus und einfach us
papier mit zuckerhut liebig bis heute
kracher und dass man meine homepage
das sind so sauer gummi lag schlangen
wie ultra haben oh mein gott
sauer und natürlich frösche aber die
meisten von euch wie ein frosch möglich
gab es und zwar nicht doch jan es hieß
der und da hatten sie so ein kiss aber
unten in der backe war so ein
vorständler eis brauchen dann gab es
eine kaugummi flüssigkeit kruste wo das
eis rhein gepumpt wurde das fertig so
geliebt dass einmal gold kann hier auf
[Musik]
bunte tüte westen bestimmt auch ganz
viele von euch lisa bund fruchtige
puffreis mit meist dass meine mama mini
gekauft und chrysler war auch nicht so
lecker
der schmeckt wie flo wenn die flut
wirksamen wollte holte diesen kopf frei
ist ist genau das gleiche werden früher
kaum geld deswegen habe ich nie die
original sachen bekommen einmal
verschoben werden muss haben weil ich
das irgendwie bei einer freundin
gegessen habe und footloose so teufel
und dann haben meine eltern irgendwann
fühlt unsere kaufen hier eine schüssel
gegessen und von das super etliche sind
packung stand noch glaube ich ein jahr
im schrank und meine mutter hat mir
seitdem nichts mehr holt weil sie immer
gesagt habe wollte auch die flut klubs
haben die also auch nicht gegessen habe
er geld von den hat jetzt kind albträume
diese glubschaugen gummiteilen die man
essen konnte laut auge
mein problem ist auch dass diese
ungefähr die größe von zum apfel haben
machen sollte man etwas essen das aus
den augen jetzt wieder andy konsistent
ich meine haltung ist es bestimmt ganz
witzig aber am 1 august ausgefallen hier
welches sie mit ihren text vergessen das
dann eine rote flüssigkeit drin ist es
schmeckt okay aber kommen nicht darauf
klar dass aus dem film wird er sagt mein
hirn einfach so nebulös ist das
nachsehen noch nicht kennt jetzt kommt
etwas richtig cooles kaugummi zigaretten
mit sie haben uns ständig geholt und
standen wir dann mal alle und haben an
den skeletten gezogen es gab auch so
zigaretten die haben so ein fake pulver
rausgeschossen das ist auch so wäre auch
super cool nach wer jemand eine kippa
das leben in der dritten klasse ist so
anstrengend aber du hast so viel zu tun
das ist diese richtige räudige kaugummi
kindheits geschmack um mein gott wenn
ihr wirklich mal wieder so ein richtigen
kindheit flash bekam gold holt ist
kaugummi zigarette schmeckt überhaupt
nicht gut also es ist nichts das ist
nichts was gut schmeckt was ist dieses
süße räudige dymo mein gott ich weiß
nicht ob ihr die kennt ich erinnere mich
so hart daran ich weiß nicht warum es
sich in meinem kopf so festgesetzt hat
aber dieses männchen mit diesem stein
aus der nase
was muss man diese kette aus wir sind
nicht so grüne kaugummi stücke und die
sind super sauer darin warum habe ich so
positive erinnerungen die oh mein gott
was ist denn da alles drin kann spuren
von folgenden farbstoffen anleiten er
171 e110 er 120 121 122 je 140 jahren
das ist der absolute müll okay meint es
nicht probiert es nicht auch wir gehen
weiter durch die reise
durch meine kindheit die eigentlich in
sachen wiedererkannt die hier auch kennt
meine kommentare was ihr von den sachen
alles gegessen
da war ich ein bisschen enttäuscht ist
nämlich der flicken league soll aber zu
meiner zeit war das der togo flick in
libyen sehr ähnlich wie fliegt man das
denn der blick im blick den weg der
flicken blick lawley also ich weiss
arbeitstag und den verkauft hat da war
der besser hat karamell so mittagspause
vorbei blicken legt ich habe mich darauf
gefreut schmecke war überhaupt nicht
also schmeckt einfach nicht gut ich
möchte jetzt erst richtig cool it was so
richtig cooles und muss mich so völlig
aus den socken haut okay leute jetzt
wird es richtig spannend die meisten
wissen bestimmt was ist es ist diese
schokolade die duh kalt essen muss und
ich habe sie als kind mal warm gegessen
und ich weiß es mir danach kotzübel war
und seitdem finde ich die so furchtbar
ich habe die nirgends wo gegessen
auch wenn es das einzige süß in dem haus
war ich hab's nicht angefasst obwohl ich
sehr gerne süßigkeiten gegessen haben
könnt euch gar nicht vorstellen was das
für eine überwindung für mich ist wenn
ich gleich auf den tisch kommt und habt
ihr ein grund nicht auszulassen
schon diese kann das ganze ding und wenn
schon denn schon
teil 3 ich nehme das ganze dinge mund
wenn schon denn schon ich hasse das so
sehr war der geruch da dreht sich echt
mein magen um
ok
[Musik]
ich möchte gar nicht so schlimm wie ich
dachte schmeckt sogar ganz gut was das
denn jetzt los
das war schon da kommt wieder da kommt
wieder dieser neben geschmack und
plötzlich muss ein kracher daraufhin
geschmacks neutralisieren
der erste ging noch beim zweiten wieder
komplett vorbei jetzt brauche ich eine
belohnung für diese heldentat gradl und
zwar die belohnung für einen helden eine
toilette sind das über für pulver
einfach so ein blaues pulver ja so wenn
du dich mit seinem freund unterhält zu
mir dann immer sein rollins chlor endet
als er mir mehr ja ich habe das gefühl
dass es nach geschmack von zum toiletten
stein es liegt wahrscheinlich nur daran
dass es aus der toilette kommt ja es ist
so eine extrem süße folge mit den ganzen
zucker das mildeste das ist war es nur
circa betrieben liebes die heißen
liebesperlen alle unter 18 hat jetzt mal
nicht zu ich muss vor die erkältung
gerade was ich sagen wollte liebesperlen
alle und 8 sind können jetzt mal kurz
nicht zu leute warum heißt es news per
die schmecken voll scheiße fiel auf
drogen
ich hab das gefühl jetzt kennt gegessen
habe einfach nur pure scheißen schlägt
pulver stangen man ja auch einfach
abreißen und dann ist der kurs drin a
sich dabei so bestand aus gefühle gut
schleck pulver superc in erinnerung ich
verstehe nicht warum ich es vergessen
kennt ihr die noch wie sie kaufen mit
kriege ich immer einen mond 3 das wollte
ich als kind immer schon gemacht hat man
damals einfach nicht gemacht weil man
nicht das geld dazu hatte groß und trägt
sein wenn man mundraum gekocht
ich habe die durch gefunden
ich will für die nächsten drei tage
nicht mehr kauen kann müssen wie ich mit
einer meiner absoluten favorite aus
meiner kindheit der wunderbar diese
weiße decke gehüllt ich kenne das nicht
mit dem spiel wir hatten das noch schön
in der hand dieser geschmack
wir waren mal in der fünften klasse auf
klassenfahrt und haben uns anderen
wunder bei gekauft die ganzen mädels wie
bekloppt namen diesem wunderbar gelegt
der geschmack ist schon ziemlich häufig
kreide gegessen
kuhlmeier lippenstift versucht euch
nicht durch ein wunder bei durch zu
weisen
jetzt wird es wieder sauer railey kd
rheine lag dem anderen das hören was das
sieht nämlich aus video das macht soll
doch deine zunge und es ist extrem sauer
aber nicht dass keine sommer
ich würde mein kind so was wohl niemals
kaufen das ist rein ist zucker was sein
hund drin und in europa wie
halsschmerzen die allerletzte sache für
heute die kennt eigentlich jeder davon
so knister steine die zum kaugummi in
den mund werden wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere
niemand die ganze packung im mundraum
extrem eklig finde ich die das war eine
sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr
süße folge und ich fühle mich ein
bisschen wie oft sogar wieder auf mein
gott ich kann hier gemeldet
die immer hobby natürlich hat die folge
gefallen weil herren zeigt mit dem
daumen nach oben und habt ihr kindheit
die sich kaum wieder erkannt und welche
die nazis kennen habe ich auf jeden fall
vergessen schreibt man die reinen die
ihr gegessen habe gute nacht leuchten
das tat ich lege mir jetzt einfach
schlafen gut gemacht
die sind